of a number one seed if that's how it
plays out shot clock at five Bailey
penetrates and the Freshman puts it up
and in Amari Bailey back at the end has
fouled out a Dem Bona injured not
available
[Applause]
[Music]
Amari Bailey and Bailey spins again nice
nice finish to that play
when they were having shooting drills
and they were staggering great block boy
recovery there by Amari Bailey think of
what he did to Maryland in a road trip
earlier this season there's just all
different ways
at you but Amari Bailey is filling it up
at gil
man started from the field for the
Huskies bailing on the drops
[Applause]
into the hoop
new but battling goes back up missed it
Dante may have blocked it imagine my
surprise
wow
[Applause]
what a play
Michael Jones is off Bailey with a
rebound
Bailey ahead of everybody and lays it in
Dylan Andrews next off the UCLA bench in
the back court playing with Bailey eight
to shoot
Bailey off the crossover able to get it
up and in he's so good at that